hello
i'm ryan wright and i'm jerry welcome to
reasons to see where we give you reasons
to see and not to see after earth so
let's hang out
we must abort this mission
you wouldn't give any other range in
that order you are not a ranger
you are my son
remember danger is very real
but fear is a choice
if we are going to survive this
we fight
all right people so
i know everyone hates this [__] movie
but not us yeah and we're we're gonna
give you reasons to see this [__]
movie reason to see number one
the story
the story to me is the is the best
reason to see this movie i loved it i
feel like people just don't get this
[__] movie it's about its messages
it's about its philosophies it's about
all these you know underlying themes and
the sci-fi story is a backdrop to it but
just the sci-fi story itself is is
[__] awesome it's an interesting
story in a sense because it's not the
big sci-fi action or you kind of think
it might be a trailer
but you know it's a story about a father
and a son trying to to
you know
save their lives basically from from
from crash landing on this horrible
planet that is in fact earth it's like
the kid has to prove himself and then
the dad has to learn to to you know let
go and let the kid you know grow and and
you know
live up to the expectation a lot of it
is about successful philosophies or how
to become a better person and stuff like
that and i know will smith he created
the story for this movie and i've seen a
ton of interviews for will smith none
not one interview for after earth but
from what i really know about the guys
he's a very deep intellectual
philosophical guy and like a lot of
successful people they know that
everything starts with thought first and
so some stuff in this movie might sound
corny or cliche something like that but
honestly it's just the truth it's like
this movie in a way is a parable to me
about facing your fears and you decide
because fear is a choice but don't
mistake me
danger is real that's a great scene too
like i really like that model if you
don't like the movie i think that's a
great monologue like i feel bad for a
night shaman because
that's the quickest way to clear a room
is to say hey you want to see the new
shyamalan picture yeah and then
everyone's gone you know like there is
sort of like a fantasy thing about it
like with its opening monologue the
description of like the heroic legend of
will smith's character just the idea of
how like the aliens can sense you or
know where you are based off you feeling
fear it's all like allegories and
metaphors and all that kind of stuff
it's like a story jesus might tell in a
way it's almost a quiet story in a sense
i like it because it's a big sci-fi
story yet it's subtly told reason to see
number two
will and jayden smith i thought they
worked really well together even though
a lot of the time they're they're
technically not on screen together but
the interaction
feels real i wasn't there going that's
will smith's kid that's will smith's kid
i believe the relationship i believe the
story i believe the characters yeah and
people are giving jaden smith a lot of
crap about this movie i thought he did a
fine job i you know i thought he was
good enough
he's not great he's not this like
outstanding guy but there are some
scenes that he has that are really good
like that moment in the trailer that you
see a lot where he's like you would have
told the other ranger to be this way i
really felt that scene yeah that was a
good scene there are certain times where
you can tell like his acting chops
aren't you know fantastic yeah exactly
but there are there are some moments
that he has that are really good and you
know i think he deserves credit for that
yeah and i liked will smith a lot i feel
like a lot of people don't get will
smith's character you know some people
are saying he sacrifices charisma i'm
like this guy has been through war and
in order to i like i like the character
growth for for both of them it's like
they both have to sort of learn how to
properly deal with fear like will smith
he sort of detached himself from his
emotions in order to not feel fear so he
sort of has to learn how to feel and how
to be loving to his family and show that
more and everything and jaden smith he
has to learn how to not be
filled with fear and to not let his
trauma rule him the characters
start and their journey even though you
know how it's probably going to end that
doesn't matter it's about the journey i
felt those messages being communicated
strongly through their performances and
i thought will smith was cool you know
it's it's hard to make a guy interesting
throughout who's just sitting in a chair
for most of the movie and i heard that
was a criticism up front and it's not
quite as it sounds it's not like he's
just lounging the whole yeah just giving
directions yeah he's like dying from the
leg pain a father and son working
through their troubled relationship in a
sense when they're isolated in a
situation together and i like the
writing of the dialogue and sometimes
the dialogue just between them creates
the tension creates the the sense of
urgency this is not a fast-paced bang
bang movie but there is a sense of
urgency there is a sense of danger going
on that moment where he's like do you
know where we are yeah this is earth
that whole
talk about what they have to get their
hair is to go all the way across the
mountains and stuff like that that's
like that's that's a big obstacle you
gotta overcome man reason to see number
three
the directing
m night shyamalan i know everyone hates
you but i i think you brought it back to
be honest buddy
good indian good indian
i haven't seen all of his recent films
but of the ones i've seen and of the
later ones i think this is for me this
was a step up you know absolutely yeah i
don't think it's a perfect movie but i
really enjoyed it and i thought that you
know he still has an able hand it's well
put together the world is very
interesting and it's a sci-fi survival
story slash father and son story and he
managed to combine all three elements
into one enjoyable picture and you know
like he knows how to still have those
touches there are moments where the
audience would jump there there are
moments where you put a couple of horror
movie moments in there just just to keep
it interesting yeah there are some
dramatic scenes there are some scary
scenes i i some people are saying this
is slow and boring i personally really
dug the tone of this film even when
you're like there's no humor right when
i've had that thought i was like i'm
laughing at something right now because
it's actually funny and it's like this
is a movie it's a survivor movie of
course it's gonna be a little slow like
i think people are expecting some sci-fi
mystery
action-adventure type of film when it is
an adventure film but it's not like this
big uplifting crazy hollywood picture
type of thing it's a subtle story
and it's more about people than it is
about some crazy sci-fi journey or
something like that the traumatic events
that help that shaped these people
make logical sense and he captured that
well and the sci-fi world is cool well
and actually some people clapped in our
theater yeah dude when the movie was
over the whole audience clapped you
gotta wonder it's like people already
kind of loadedly hate m night shyamalan
and jaden smith movies it kind of seems
par for the course that they're like
well yeah [__] that movie reason to see
number four
cinematography
yeah when this movie started that was
the first thing i noticed i was just
looking for things to hate when the
movie first started but when i was
watching i was going you know the
cinematography actually looks really
good it's the i love the lighting i love
the whole just the picture in general
they really knew how to capture the
landscapes of everything perfectly well
i thought it was gorgeously shot it was
it was a beautiful film to look at and
the cinematography is absolutely
excellent you know it has that sort of
floaty futuristic look to it and just
the combination of the design of
everything with the way they captured it
is is great and they use you know
the handheld cam just the right ways
it's not like star trek where
everything's always moving yeah yeah but
it is you know
it's just enough
for what it is you know yeah exactly it
communicates its tone well through the
visual imagery reason to see number five
visual effects
this movie costs like 130 million
dollars to make and when if i just heard
the story i wouldn't think the amount of
money is necessary probably still isn't
but the visual effects were awesome in
this film like they're when you're
dealing with like creatures animals that
we're familiar with that have sort of
evolved in a way to kill humans it's
hard to find visual effects that match
and the cinematography working well with
visual effects as i notice what really
helps visual effects is the lighting
based off the cinematographer and the
visual effects in this when he was like
battling weird looking creatures i
wasn't there going that's so fake i i
was believing it and there were times
there was a little there was there was
tension there and stuff like that and
not all of the effects were entirely
convincing to me there were a couple
creatures where i was like yes that is
cg there were some other creatures
though that looked spectacular so yeah
you know and especially the space
sequences and the cities and all sorts
and i thought the alien was pretty scary
ryan's consensus [__] most movie critics
there are plenty of reasons to see after
earth [__] most movie critics there are
plenty of reasons to see after earth
yeah i think people just don't like m
night shyamalan and don't want to give
him another chance jerry's consensus
there are more reasons than you would
expect to see after earth there are more
reasons than you would expect to see
after earth yeah man like i said i
wasn't excited at all going into this
movie and coming out you know i'm not
i'm not quite as in love with it as you
are but i i enjoyed it quite a bit and i
think it's definitely a step up for
eminent shyamalan like what i have to
say is this like i've had to do a lot of
growing in my personal life like i was a
very different person
my best friend here can totally vouch
for that through a lot of the messages
and philosophies portrayed in this movie
i think this movie has a much more
personal feeling to me because i had to
really learn to apply and internally
have it you know form in me in order for
those things to change help change my
life that's why i really love this movie
because it's been a while since i've
seen a movie that communicates those
messages so well all right people thanks
for checking out our review for after
earth why don't you go ahead scroll to
that comment box below and tell us what
is your favorite m9 shyamalan movie or
the worst m night shyamalan movie you
have ever seen if you want to check out
more episodes of reasons to see click
this link right here and if you want to
check out my straight to the point
review of after earth why don't you
click the link right here and last but
not least if you want to get updated
every time a new review or a video is
out
subscribe subscribe
because you have to subscribing is a
choice take a knee and subscribe yeah
kneel on your keyboard be in the present
moment
sight sound
touch
what if he was like
i have a mysterious erection
dad what should i do
that would be the bamboos are attacking
me and i have a boner for some reason
that would be a very
different coming of age yeah the aliens
can sense you if you have fear or a
boner
that was the original draft of the
script yeah they they decided they
didn't want to have an r rated
like we need to make as much money as
possible this was originally a sex
comedy in the scientific world yeah
exactly yeah and then they're like let's
just
need a little bit more for families
father-son sex comedy is a very very
niche
yes all right come here
you